today's questions from Victor in Arizona
I'm 64 years old debt-free close to
retirement I'm planning to co-sign on a
house for my daughter as well as give
her the 20% down which constitutes 30%
of my total savings the total amount is
$300,000 and she only qualifies for 150
I want to help her out but I'm not sure
this is a good idea can you advise you
do not have the money to help her at the
level you're helping her and she can
only live in a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar house by herself oh poor
little thing Oh God really seriously you
know no no no no no unbelievable no you
do not cosign for your kids mortgage
period they rent till they get their
crap together okay and if you want to
give them some money to help them with
the down payment on the house or give
them enough money to buy a house I don't
care but it should be a reasonably small
percentage of your net worth so you're
saying you're going to give her enough
to put 20% down
but that's one third of your entire nest
egg so let's play a game let's say
that's a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars you own do your name and you're
getting ready to give her 50 dude have
you ever told this princess no seriously
no I mean you can afford to give her
about 1/4 of what you're giving her in
cash and you cannot afford to cosign
translation she can't afford the house
she wants hope I wasn't unclear hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]